[Як ми пережили весну 2020?]
[Ukraїner
на карантині]
В Україні на три тижні запровадили карантин.
Таке рішення ухвалили сьогодні
на засіданні Кабінету міністрів.
Зокрема закриють усі навчальні заклади,
заборонять масові заходи
за участі понад 200 осіб,
а спортивні змагання проводитимуть
лише з дозволу міжнародних організацій,
але без глядачів.
♪ [грають на музичних інструментах
ритмічну музику] ♪
[Ната Жижченко, Євген Філатов
Музиканти, лідери гуртів ONUKA та The Maneken]
♪ [грають на музичних інструментах
ритмічну музику] ♪
♪ [на тлі лунає ритмічна музика] ♪
[Дмитро Бартош
Фотограф, волонтер Ukraїner]
Ти, Діма, пам'ятай, у Гогена
було складне життя.
Як у мене.
Ні, гірше. А може й краще.
Кинув жінку, хорошу зарплату і поїхав...
В експедицію Ukraїner?
[сміється] Ні.
Все-все, не розмовляй, будь ласка.
Краще мовчи.
Вважаю, що час на карантині
треба проводити з користю.
[Альона Савраненко
Реп-виконавиця, відома як alyona alyona]
Я от, наприклад, вчуся грати на гітарі.
Потрошку.
Як виходить.
♪ [грає на гітарі] ♪
[Наріман Алієв
Кінорежисер]
♪ [лунає меланхолійна фортепіанна музика] ♪
Карантин в Україні, скоріш за все, продовжать,
про це заявив головний санітарний
лікар України Віктор Ляшко.
Він сказав, що рішення щодо можливого продовження карантину прийматиметься
в залежності від епідемічної ситуації
в країнах Європи та на території України.
[Сергій Ковальов
Фотограф дикої природи]
Довгий час я мріяв поїхати в далеку подорож,
щоб знімати дику природу, тварин.
Придбав для цього багато обладнання,
зробив багато планів.
Всі зірки зійшлися саме на цей рік.
Коли вірус замкнув нас по своїх домівках,
довелося вивчати дику природу
з балкона четвертого поверху.
Тим не менш, це виявилося дуже цікаво.
Головне, зрозумівши, що переміщення
по світу замкнулося на довгі місяці,
я почав привертати більше уваги
до національних парків України,
їхнім дивам та проблемам.
В підсумку переосмислив те,
що маю робити в майбутньому.
[пташки співають]
[Марко Галаневич
Музикант, учасник гурту DakhaBrakha]
Всім привіт, я Марко Галаневич.
Я на карантині, як і всі люди.
[собака гавкає, дитина говорить]
Що, доню?
Я маю перекусити трошки?
Давай. Пісочок.
[плямкає]
— Дуже дякую. Це що, був борщик?
— Так.
Дуже дякую.
Всім привіт.
[Наталка Біда
Акторка, учасниця гурту Dakh Daughters]
У нас на карантині з Марком
з'явилася прекрасна можливість
побути разом набагато більше,
ніж під час гастролей.
[дитина говорить нерозбірливо]
— О, давай борщу.
— Борщик їмо.
— Разом з родиною.
— Так.
І цінуймо те, що у нас є.
♪ [на тлі лунає джазова музика] ♪
[Віта Бартош
Художниця, викладачка мистецтв]
Вуха стирчать.
Очима [дивись] кудись туди, в нікуди.
Пальці вирівняли.
Розслабимо.
Поезія,
теплі острови,
смуглі таїтянки,
оце все в погляді мені, будь ласка, покажи.
Багато смуглих таїтянок.
[клацає затвор фотоапарата, лунають дитячі крики]
Все, так.
Жужа.
Пішли.
Йдемо гуляти?
Тут у нас така імпровізована буферна зона.
Місце, куди можна ставати тільки,
якщо ти вже взутий.
[Віктор Грудаков
Графічний дизайнер]
У нас тут є дві коробочки.
В одній ми зберігаємо ключі і речі, якими
ми користуємося на вулиці. В другій так само.
В дім вони не заносяться
і час від часу ми їх дезінфікуємо.
Взуття також.
Після того, як я починаю збиратися й одягатися,
то я вже обличчя руками не чіпаю,
бо я чіпав ті речі до того.
Київ став містом з найбруднішим повітрям у світі.
Через сильний вітер у столиці
виникла пилова буря,
яка підняла верхні шари ґрунту у повітря.
[англійською] І Оскар йде до...
[Євгенія Сапожникова
Редакторка Ukraїner]
Київське небо.
Вперше за чотири дні таке блакитне і чисте.
Можна дихати,
не закриваючи ніс рукою.
Танцюю.
[плескає в долоні]
[Софійка Сапожникова]
Коли одужаємо і всі одужають, то ми поїдемо у подорож.
Або в Карпати,
або до дідуся, або до бабулі Люди.
Так, обов'язково.
[Поліна Забіжко
Фотографка, волонтерка Ukraїner]
Величезна проблема
посилення карантину була в тому,
що всі заборони сумбурні,
і ти не знаєш, що ще зміниться
в твоїх обмеженнях.
Ситуація, в якій ти абсолютно нічого
не контролюєш,
дуже виносить голову, дуже діє на нерви.
Таким чином,
мої емоційні проблеми були дуже швидко
вирішені за допомогою кур'єрства.
Тому що поки я б сиділа вдома
і не знала, куди себе діти,
я фізично працювала.
[Саша Буль
Музикант, композитор]
Привіт, мене звати Саша Буль, мені 31 рік.
Я — музикант.
Свій карантин я проводжу неподалік Чернівців.
Якби не коронавірус, я б напевне
ніколи не навчився вирощувати овочі,
працювати на землі,
працювати з рослинами.
Чесно кажучи, не можу сказати, що це
подобається мені менше, ніж музика.
Теж отримую від цього величезне задоволення.
Проводжу дуже багато часу на природі,
що в принципі завжди любив.
Так і живу, в ізоляції.
Без людей, але з природою.
Карантин в Україні триватиме
щонайменше до 22 червня,
таке рішення ухвалив уряд.
Мотивували продовження обмежень тим,
що нині країна перебуває
на піку захворюваності на COVID-19.
Отже про значне зменшення
кількості інфікованих говорити зарано.
[плюскіт води]
♪ [лунає музика з мему] ♪
[звук затвора фотоапарата]
Може хай тато палітру рівніше тримає.
Та ні, нормально.
[звук затвора фотоапарата]
Вікно не відображає?
Ні, зовсім не видно.
— Все, я думаю, ми закінчили.
— Я теж все?
[втомлено зітхає]
[Розкажіть у коментарях,
як ви провели цю весну]
[Автор
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Ресьорчерка
Юлія Безпечна]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Ukraїner
на карантині]